elle était le symbole et le visage de la
guerre diplomatique entre les États-Unis
et la Russie la basketeuse Britney
grinder est libre emprisonné pour trafic
de drogue à la BTS en février dernier
dans un aéroport de Moscou avec une
vapoteuse et du liquide contenant du
cannabis sa libération a eu lieu grâce à
un échange avec des prisonniers russes
parmi lesquels Victor boot trafiquant
d'armes rendu célèbre grâce à un film
hollywoodien il était en prison depuis
plus de 10 ans
avec un trouble neurologique très rare
appelé en anglais Steve personn
el
sur un million on a compilé plusieurs
moments pendant lesquels la première
ministre s'autorise à vapoter plus ou
moins discrètement dans des lieux fermés
dans l'hémicycle à plusieurs reprises
sous le moyen c'est une petite technique
voilà mais aussi au Sénat et vous voyez
même pendant un conseil des ministres
qui s'est déroulé en présence d'une
vingtaine d'enfants je n'ai pas d'autre
choix
que de me concentrer sur ma santé
et j'ai bon espoir
ras-le-bol de voir encore et encore
Elisabeth borne vapoter tranquillement
pendant que je pose une question au
gouvernement ou encore c'est sympa quand
on fait les règles elle s'applique
seulement aux autres le patron de RTL
affirme il n'y aura aucune coupure de
courant ce mois-ci avant la fin de
l'année non et après la fin de l'année
et au début de l'année prochaine il faut
pas paniquer nous réalisons un certain
nombre de scénarios qui sont finalement
des hypothèses sur lesquels nous
travaillons en fait on nous envoie
du covid faites passif faites pas ça et
alors surtout ne faites pas comme je
fais
c'est à dire que moi je prends l'avion
je fais le tour du monde mais alors
surtout vous il faut pas que vous
preniez l'avion la voiture
d'après Le Parisien on apprend qu'il
grelotte dans les dans les ministères
est-ce qu'il fait froid au ministère du
Travail je vais vous dire ça dépend des
pièces parce que le ministère du Travail
est une vieille maison c'est une
passoire thermique mais c'est-à-dire que
ils n'ont aucune connaissance réelle de
la situation qui sont ils sont hors-sols
et ils sont très très loin la réalité on
a une salle de réunion qui s'appelle la
salle des accords dans laquelle j'ai
passé une partie de l'après-midi je peux
vous assurer qu'on était pas à 19 ans
mais plutôt être à 13 ou 14 mais pas 19
vues combien nous gros Lotter lorsque
l'on arrive en 2012 où il décide que on
passe de 75% du nucléaires à 50 lois qui
depuis 5 ans n'a pas changé et on
continue à être sur cet objectif alors
qu'on sait que cet objectif est
inatteignable stupide et nous conduit
dans le mur les ministres alarmes le
président Kajol Bad Cop good COP la
communication selon Starsky et Hutch la
ficelle est un peu grosse mais bon on
fera semblant d'y croire face à la
remontée de l'épidémie et de la
conjonction
parce que c'est bien de faire de la
pédagogie parce qu'on n'a pas envie de
revenir vers les obligations
généralisées forcément et donc c'est
aussi une manière de reprendre des
habitudes basées sur le volontariat
d'esprit de responsabilité voilà mais il
a par ailleurs profite il se déplacement
pour annoncer la gratuité des
préservatifs dès 2023 pour les 18 25 ans
les bouches d'égout elle se sont
transformées en geyser
rien qu'hier il est tombé en à peine une
heure dans la capitale portugaise
l'équivalent de trois semaines de pluie
le ticket gagnant il n'y en a qu'un les
vainqueurs ils sont 165 un groupe
d'habitants de la commune d'olmen en
Belgique ce cotise pour jouer à l'Euro
Millions avec le projet de se partager
le butin si le bon tirage tombe c'est
mon avis c'est foutu non mais là vous
avez raison là vous avez raison
de menaces pour une société c'est foutu
ma conviction c'est foutu le groupe
d'habitants a remporté près de 143
millions d'euros soit un gain de presque
900 000 euros par personne de quoi
sortir le champagne